make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
apparently a lot of you guys didn't know
that i have the pop culture explained
channel and that we're actually on tick
tock as well because we had a video we
had the the video that we were talking
about with one division we took a
segment of it put it on tick tock and it
went viral it got something like 80
000 views at least at the moment that
we're recording this right now and the
comments were full of people like this
sounds like rob from comics explained
are you rob from comics explained
so yeah guys keep in mind we have the
pop culture explained channel i think
right now we just crossed i think
we crossed 10 000 subscribers i think
we're at almost 10 and a half thousand
now
um and the tick tock's blowing up as
well right at pop culture explained on
tick tock uh but it's cool man i
love doing the pop cult i love doing the
pop culture explain channel it's
literally everything i hoped it would be
it's it's amazing plus all the wanda
vision theories are fun
but uh but we are covering we're
covering the king in black part three
man let me tell you something okay
here's the thing man here's the thing
okay here's the thing this story is
legit i don't know if you guys heard
but donnie cates and ryan stegman are
leaving venom with issue number 200
they're going to be done and i was so
disappointed because this is one of
those things where i kind of wish they'd
just write it forever right
it's kind of disappointing to know
they're going to be leaving but it's
okay
right all good things must come to an
end as disappointing as it may be so
what this does is this initially picks
up kind of in the aftermath right and we
get this this this sort of
monologue right now for those of you
guys who know who this monologue is
coming from please do not tell
anybody because it's not coming from
thor it's it's
it's cool but don't tell please don't
tell anybody it's it's a dude the reveal
at the end is amazing it's absolutely
amazing
but uh but but this this monologue kind
of tells us that like in the universe
there's always like a light in the dark
right there's there's always
uh you know opposing forces good versus
evil light versus dark right
right versus wrong and it's one of these
things that's kind of iconic of this
particular character right offering
these just amazing monologues
and one of the things that it talks
about is that on this singular world out
there in this
infinitely expanding universe is a young
kid who lost his dad right a single
fatherless boy
and he of course is referring to dylan
but while that's going on one of the
things to keep in mind
is they're literally like the
superheroes who are there basically have
their backs against the wall remember
like eddie brock was believed to have
been their ace in the hole
right the hope was that eddie brock
would be able to overcome null dylan
does possess the ability to do it but
nobody really knows if dylan's powers
are
expanded enough or if he's strong enough
to be able to overcome
null so if he goes out there who knows
how things may go right but the other
thing that we also know from going on
from from the story
with iron man and doctor doom is that
tony stark now has a symbiote armor he's
got a new suit of armor that's based on
a combination of extremists and symbiote
tech right so he can basically
manipulate
and and seemingly control the various uh
symbiotes of null or the very least
influence them we don't really know the
full limitations of it but we'll
actually find out in the story
some of the stuff that he can do and so
while that's going on you end up having
reed richards who's doing a little bit
of investigation on his own
in the sense that there's a character
called wraith he doesn't really matter
but he basically gave eddie brock this
kind of
encrypted drive that has all this
information and basically points to
where dylan's powers are coming from
right so we may cover that if you guys
really want to see it we can but i don't
really think it's important that we do
raith is a character who pops up from
time to time he was in like annihilation
conquest i think or like annihilation
he's one of these guys that shows up
every once in a while and marvel just
kind of uses him for exposition and then
that's it right so it doesn't really
serve any useful purpose
uh but while all that's going on they're
kind of investigating they're trying to
figure things out
what's left of the superhuman community
you've got iron man you've got
uh magneto you've got charles xavier so
basically you know iron man and the
mutants on krakowa you've got name of
the submariner you've got uh carol
danvers you've got susan storm who are
all basically talking to reed and the
reality is they're only some of the few
that are left right you've got susan
storm alongside blade
and she's of course using her force
field to hold off these these symbiote
guys as best she can that blade's got
his
his you know vampire army that's
fighting these guys off as best they can
but at the end of the day is only really
a stopgap measure because this is really
just a battle of attrition that's all it
is right the forces of null number in
the millions if not the billions at this
point because the symbiotes are just
bonding to so many people
all over the world and so fighting
against such overwhelming odds pushes
people's powers to the extreme as strong
as susan storm is with her force field
she can't hold it forever now if i'm
being honest with you guys
i feel like this is a little bit of
inconsistency with her character
right because if we read jonathan
hickman's fantastic four you guys
remember that in that story she held her
force field up against the power of the
celestials these are basically guys
bonded to symbiotes right so
it stands to reason if we take that
ability her ability to withstand the
power of celestials and bring it here
then she should be well within her
ability to hold these guys back
you know for a pretty lengthy amount of
time too but it's just one of these
things where sometimes those
inconsistencies kind of fly under the
radar right and so the result of this is
that you end up having tony stark who
chimes in and says okay look like
dylan's gonna
have to go out there and do his thing
but don't worry i have a plan uh i've
gotta i've got a way through this right
i've got a way for us
to be able to pull this off now that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
once they get out there it's kind of
what you expect to see from the
superheroes right
you've got spider-man out here you've
got uh you got wolverine out here you've
got all these guys who are out here and
their goal isn't necessarily to kill
all these people right because of the
fact that they're basically innocent
people bonded to symbiotes so they're
not destroyed it's not like the what if
secret war story from back in 1980
wherever where you end up finding out
that like after it was all said and done
that the symbiote had actually consumed
peter parker and all that was left was
just the symbiote and his bones right
it's not like that that has just bonded
to these people and once they find a way
to separate the symbiote away from these
individuals then they can return them
back to the way they were before you get
this really really amazing moment here
right where captain america comes
running in
with the intention of trying to take out
dylan and he throws his shield and dylan
just catches it in mid-air
and he's like i'm gonna need to borrow
this and it's amazing it's this really
amazing moment
because you've got this little kid dylan
running around with like captain america
shield
right he just like blasts the symbiote
off captain america right and it's one
of these things where he reaches out to
null and he's like no i know you're out
there i know you're watching this
let me know if you can feel this and if
you can i hope it hurts and like blows
the symbiote off of captain america
right so like right there he makes his
presence known to null and noah's like
there you are like i've been looking for
you all this time there you are right so
immediately like immediately finds this
kid
and that's when it all pops off because
as soon as he realizes dylan's there he
immediately goes after him and while
captain america has returned back to his
normal self
dylan is not able to hold off against
the against the power of null right he's
not able to pull this off
it's just it's not able to happen and so
because of that in this moment when null
is basically getting ready to subdue
so do dylan this lightning comes flying
out of nowhere it's like
right this lightning comes flying out of
nowhere and then here comes thor
and it's just it's like oh my god it's
like it's like the most thor entrance
ever
thor showing up here is one of these
things where he's like how do i help and
dylan's like just have my back now the
crazy thing is that
while this happens we get another
monologue from like this mystery guy and
this mystery guy is like again like
every good out there there's an evil
right for every source out there
there is there's this opposite and
because of the fact that thor
has the power of lightning he literally
uses it and just starts
blowing the symbiotes off of all these
different guys or at least alongside
alongside dylan right like thor is the
one that kind of incapacitates them with
his lightning and then dylan's the one
who blows the symbiotes off of them
right but basically
bringing back all these different
superheroes that we've seen fall to the
power of null but
the crazy thing is that as that happens
and those symbiotes are basically
destroyed you end up having null who
finally makes this presence known who
finally comes down and this is a big
deal right because with null he only
ever really like
comes in and deals with things
personally if things are popping off in
a really bad way right like if he's if
he's losing the upper hand is the only
time he really does it right so
so noel comes comes like showing up here
and immediately starts talking trash
right because at a previous point in
time
thor had destroyed one of the grindel
dragons of null which is how nole became
aware of who thor was now they've never
really encountered each other properly
before they've never actually met this
is the first time they're actually
meeting each other but the crazy thing
is noel starts going on this rant about
you know i'm a god from the void and all
that kind of stuff
king of the abyss and so on and he's
like he's like i am and thor's like
quiet
right like i'm the last person that
you're ever going to impress with your
pitiful stupid titles so you may as well
stop now right like you're a god you're
a king that's cool
so am i and like the two of them just go
crashing headlong into each other the
crazy thing about that is again we're
talking about null this is a guy who
subdued celestials he's not your
your villain of the week right so as
powerful as thor
is he subdued immediately and what this
shows us is that with regards to the
power of null he
he transcends the the abilities of a sky
father right like the thor force the
equivalent of the odin force for thor
that kind of a thing
how this translates to whether or not
noah will be able to defeat odin
don't really know right we don't have an
answer to that somebody would have to
write that comic in order to give us an
answer otherwise we're just cooking the
books right we're just making up things
and so on and i'm not really a huge fan
of that but it's one of these crazy
situations
because with thor basically being
subdued uh null actually kind of ignores
dylan for a second and then continues to
take out thor and the reason for that
the reason why this is so important is
because
thor's a credible threat to null right
thor is the first time that we've seen
somebody show up and actually start
giving null
a run for his money and that's what
really worries him that behind the
besiege behind the facade of you know i
know and all that kind of stuff there's
fear there right there's fear like he's
afraid of the fact that thor could take
him out right because thor has
mjolnir he's got the thor force right
like he's kind of afraid of that but
ultimately you end up having null who
kind of gets the upper hand here and
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because in this process
null basically dawns the necro sword
right like he literally bought
he literally creates the necro sword but
it happens after this amazing moment
right so with thor
going after null he comes charging at
him with like the full brunt of his
hammer and literally
knocks the jaw off null's face like he
literally knocks off the bottom half of
his jaw
knocks the jaw off his face and it's
like holy hell right like it's one of
these things like if it bleeds we can
kill it right arnold schwarzenegger from
predator that's basically what this is
and so in response to that noel's like
fine
enough if that's the kind of game you
want to play then i can play that game
and he activates the celestials right
and says okay
like we're waking the celestials up it's
time to start using them while that
happens he draws the necro sword and in
this moment when thor's back is turned
null stabs him through the back right he
just just stabs it right through the
back so like thor
just like that seemingly taken out and
in that moment all hell
like it all just seems lost right reed's
like okay i have no idea what we're
gonna do now
thor's down we have some of the
superheroes who were back but they
weren't enough to take out knoll hence
the reason why they were captured in the
first place like
like the celestials are activated now
what do we do here
cue iron man right iron man comes
swooping in with with his literally
literally with a suit and it's one of
these things where he's like because
this is a blend
between the symbiotes and and extremists
i can basically
create my own symbiotes now right and
that's what he does he creates like this
giant dragon he's like i can just i can
just create my own thing right
this this symbiote does whatever i
command it to right it does whatever it
is that i wanted to
and so he's like what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna come in there as fast as i can
but at the end of the day like i'm just
gonna take over one of these celestials
right i'm gonna take over
a celestial armor using my symbiote suit
and then
i'm basically going to beat up the other
celestial iron man
basically creates his own celestial
buster armor
that's crazy right like it's the
craziest thing right to literally
take over an entire celestial and then
use them
for your own hands right you guys see
how ridiculously epic
this story is dude it's nuts i told you
guys donnie kate's man this guy is a
wizard when it comes to writing stories
this guy is
nuts it's it's it's absolutely bonkers
but that's kind of the crazy thing is
that with thor
incapacitated kind of you know
essentially down for the count that you
end up having uh having null who
basically tries to make his move for
dylan right
in that moment you have thor who sends
the ravens out and he says like he's
like
go and find them right like fly fly as
fast as you can
and go and find him and that's the
person who's narrating right because
this guy comes in
and like we get this this monologue is
amazing right he says for every darkness
there is a light
an opposite an equal there is another an
opposite of null a god of light the
source of dylan's power
but while null's dome still stands it
cannot break through
but i i can't and we find out the
mystery person that's basically doing
this monologue is none other
than the silver surfer with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
cliffhangers make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the rob
core cliffhangers
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and i will catch you all
later
peace i love leaving you guys on
cliffhangers i know i'm terrible
i know i'm a horrible person but i love
doing it
[Music]
you